I'm very excited to talk about this
because we do a lot of stuff by the show
that all the crazy shit
that in our food all the WAC Dow
Chemical that are in yoga mats that
you're reading a
think so I am and everything else that
every time we do want the story the
comment section go crazy
and they yell at me and they say I'm
anti-science because I'm even bringing
this up and it in there and it's not
gonna kill you that seems to be a
general team
I think it weird that we Bieber anal
gland use and
and I love labor I think that we're tied
it may not kill me I just think it odd
that someone
with squeezing the Bieber is a decent
but stays good
grow up the what I want to be that guy
but I understand a little more about
times than I do and break somebody
stepped down because you might have
heard this week the coca-cola has
announced
that it's not going to use brominated
vegetable oil oil
or Bebo in soft drinks such as bad
fresca and Powerade anymore I and this
comes after a lot of people were talking
online
about how BBDO is related to compounds
that are found in fire retardant
so let's look at a little more info on
Bebo
it contain the chemical bromide which is
also founded by retarded
said small quantities a BB or legally
allowed in some drinks to ensure
even labor distribution according to the
Center for Science in the Public
Interest
bebo is a poorly tested and possibly
dangerous food additive and there's no
reason to use it in Gatorade
or other drinks a so before we get to
the next thing I want to stop there for
a second because as I said when we do
this every one
yells at me they say what you don't eat
a ton a bit you'll be okay we put
chemicals in our body all the time and
everything
as chemicals in the Inc has is getting
chemical thing is gay but
and you made a chemical and you're
making ever go today all of that right
yeah all of that so can you guys give me
just sorta
a basic break something can you give me
something to pick this conversation of
so I'll start by saying that I think
that the people in the comment section
there's a lot of validity to what
they're saying because they're is as a
especially in liberal media their is
kinda up quick
tech to immediately be afraid have
anything
that corporation produces abt and
immediately be afraid of words like
molecule can I call an hour and
you know and all the Senate on dangers
we have this debate all the time with
genetically modified organisms we have
this debate with you no preservatives
food additives whatever
yeah so their is I'll
their is a reason to kind of stop sit
back and think about this
rationally okay I'm on board of the
all-star their ok now I personally
don't know much about Bevo as a food
additive
but when organizations that are there to
protect the public interest
are do their research and do their due
diligence is a okay
we don't know much about this there are
many nations that have banned it
I no that's not reason enough for us to
you but
the clincher for me there's no reason
for it to be there because you can have
the same effect if you use something
that's been proven to be
say right why aren't we using the thing
day I me think about having to do with
money yeah do you think possibly
it could be a financial decision
probably and the cool thing
I think about living in the Internet age
is that if enough people get wind
have an issue and write a petition and
get loud about it and say I'm gonna buy
your product anymore because I'm
I'm afraid if there's one thing that
you're using it that I don't think
has been clearly tested and I'm not sure
about the health benefits of it
will just stop by coca-cola products
Google have to respond
they see a drop in profit and then make
their product better even if
night killing us they can make it more
natural and that you may not have a good
basic is it fair to say
that things that are natural are
basically good number I want to get the
economic argument yet
everything is natural yeah every girl
record any artificial stuff yeah
it occurs in nature match I don't I hate
to be that Nikki but I know that
everybody can I help please no but i
mean it's true and I think it's a good
to fine things you think are unhealthy
point them out
and replace them with some things better
especially that think that's better is
available at a while he said we're not
already using that to begin with but
yeah
money but there's a lot of people out
there who
like to think about the things and they
freak out about it because they want to
be like I'm health-conscious
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna take this
initiative and do better with this issue
but they're ignoring everything else
like they're ignoring the ammonia that
people used to disinfect meet there are
no ring all the hard things like him
I mean yeah I mean there's just so many
things out there that are exponentially
worse
but nobody cares about to hop onto this
one issue and feel better about
themselves as a whole because they're
taking care one tiny little detail okay
to just to talk about the things I
projected to get everybody nuts and
we've got a couple videos on it
so basically they're taking the worst
the worst meet stop literally it's
falling on the floor
then they pile it all together they wash
it with ammonia you were knocking they
watch it with ammonia to kill
all the E-coli horrible sup it on there
and then we'd any is
edible it is humid before they do that
process it's not even fit for human
consumption
the meat and that and then it is but
when we don't videos not even then
people say well they've done what
they're supposed to do so it's okay but
you wouldn't you would not agree with
that
now I wouldn't accept that was washed
with bleach either I mean
it doesn't matter what they've done to
it two different but it's still really
unhealthy not to mention all the
hormones and stuff that you find in me
right it's just I mean really bad for
you I
take a really nuanced approach you like
specifically for talking about pink
slime
that because let's say that I am living
in
the inner city and I don't have the
monetary means to eat at Whole Foods
yeah
and I don't have them the means to grow
my own I mean
ho courtly II like the idea of getting
back to a slow food movement
I like the idea of getting back to you
the ones you can get to the source of
your food
if there's you are steps that it takes
before that makes it your mouth
it more likely I think generally
speaking I'm not gonna say as a rule
but generally speaking it more likely
that that food will be
healthier the left process to get the
more process to get the the more we get
into this conversation
about food that weirdly
kinda paradoxically make this obese but
also
make this malnourished and that's a huge
problem in in this country specifically
but of that
going into other Western nations so when
it but when you say
if something more natural it's probably
better for you that bullshit because I
can eat shit
this flyer yeah like and I go out to eat
throughout shit like that natural enough
ended up getting ready for bed cashier
yeah there are certain things that
a we talk about that first-ever hardly
dangers the you know there's
toxic things all over the place in
nature and kemp Kenneth
have been able to extract things and to
you a
to add things together in such a way
that they take natural ingredients and
make powerful drugs out of them
and make powerful substances and make
food use food science to make things
that taste better and that or whatever
and so I think the issue is as you
always like to say this is an important
point
follow the money like what is the goal
here is the goal feeding people and and
feeding them nutritious food or is the
goal
you know a a multinational corporations
profit motive
coca-cola and I'm the first to admit I
love cocoa and injured
everyday like my biggest life it's
horrible for you that brought you a big
ass Coca Cola drink
I think we'll always a big idea all
night like I don't forget to call I
don't smoke I don't do drugs that my by
like that is my life but it's not good
for you like in no sense of the term is
drinking a coke something that you need
for good basic nutrition high fructose
corn syrup and I could be in my arms
feel completely screwy causes all sorts
a
health problems like liver problems and
diabetes like your body shouldn't take
in
much sugar yeah so what we're talking
about here
is are these corporations making
decisions in the best interests of your
help
probably not the probably making
decisions in the best interest up their
profits as you mentioned so we need
legislation
we need regulation that protect the
consumer
we also shouldn't be so trigger-happy
that every time we hear the word
chemical
make the shake in our boat because
everything it may never happen
Open Beta Kappa okay so speaking at the
corporation for the
the big thing that kick this off a
couple months ago was the subway thing
that we've alluded to
and the chemical that is in the bread or
was in the bag that nothing as called
adan let's get some more info about ADA
its primary use is in plastic and rubber
products like yoga mat and flip flops
where it used to make them softer and
more stretchy thought you wonder
why the bread at Subway so plot be in
stretchy you think maybe if I do that
many bread products often contain a DA
which is used to make
job more elastic an ATA is known to
increase the risk
asthma allergies and skin problems and
we got a
with a buncha food that actually contain
a DA
mcdonnell's binds chick-fil-a sandwiches
Burger King bun
Dunkin Donuts Wendy's bread our birthday
guys called I mean everything
pretty much everything I don't see it
out on there which is nice a
so how should we fear this because this
this one seems a little more close to
home to me cuz
you can sorta like really tangibly see
why the bread
you mean you get great if you get
regular you go to a bakery and get a
bread
it's not as floppy and stretchy so there
is some connection between the robbery
feeling
a yoga mat and this bread so can I at
least make that well let can you guys
grab raid in our minds like
just because it has a one-component
doesn't mean we're eating yoga mat
like I think that that is the thing we
immediately jumped yeah I'd like
okay this chemical found in these two
products so therefore these two products
are the same thing
yeah and don't know we are not eating
yoga mat let's get that clear we are
currently hate that jump a little bit
more like this one
we we don't know if those quantities in
there were harmful I don't think there's
enough research but again if you can
make it without the damn thing
yeah and it and there's even a chance
that it's
more healthy for the consumer then there
you go that's a great idea
I mean why not and I do like that the
power up the consumers
collective boy made a change for Subway
because that way tried to tout
themselves as a more healthy alternative
and they don't want to have things in
their food that are going to make health
conscious consumers
turn away but if you're really that
concerned about it
the first option would be don't eat fast
food just going oh yeah
at the end of the day by about having is
that really the end there you get at
least get that out that's what I've been
thinking this whole time like I don't
want to say you shouldn't fix a problem
that exists because
if you can you something healthier than
use it but at the same time
you're freaking out over one chemical
whenever you're eating
a mcdonald's hamburger think about what
you're eating at home wrote that isn't
all the crap it's in there and you're
freaking out about
ADA playwright it just seemed a little
bit and also I know the people will make
the economic argument that you talked
before the say they're not they don't
have access to this other food and
things of that nature
but I do think that you know you could
buy canned tuna for a dollar fifty
and yes to pride I've mercury poison is
my my my yeah
but there are some cheaper ways to eat
think I know it's not as quick as
McDonald's but there are ways
so it's not totally tied up with you is
stacked against you
my advice is never throw up your hands
and just give up bright
yes this deck is stacked against you and
unfortunately you're going to the people
in certain economic situation
having left options and it's going to be
harder to make healthy decisions and so
yes that
fucking thought unfair and I think we
should be pushing
to have more healthy grocery options in
lower-income neighborhoods
I'm not saying that it the auction or
the best option is just fucking eat
McDonalds and cry about it like
obviously fast food is not healthy like
point-blank
it's just not healthy to eat fast food
and as you said
wiry nit-picking about this one thing
when there's a million other reasons
that fast food is not healthy
yes of for healthier options but let's
all keep in mind
as we're sitting here in our comfy
chairs in West Hollywood
to that some people don't have the
options that we have so we should at
least maintain perspective about
technically we're in Culver City we are
right for you nations were calling on
people wouldn't know who had it right
for you
something that they had a referendum
up